look at the crisis on the southern
border tonight the president putting his
vice president in charge
of fixing the problem this comes one day
before
his formal first news conference
since the inauguration white house
correspondent peter ducey
starts us off tonight good evening peter
good evening brett this afternoon the
president huddled with the cabinet
secretaries in charge of
border security and in charge of migrant
shelters and he told them
that the u.s government effort to fix
the mess at the border will
be led now by the vice president kamala
harris
because she's the most qualified first
to do it just two days after the vice
president laughed off a question about a
border trip
not today she became the point person
for talks with mexico guatemala and
honduras
the people of our countries i believe
need
to help stem the tide that we have seen
after weeks of denying requests from the
press to see where unaccompanied kids
are being held
the administration led a small group of
press on a tour of an hhs
shelter they picked president biden
thinks places like this are filling up
because of
natural disasters drug trafficking and
trump so this new surge we're dealing
with now started with the last
administration but it's our
responsibility
to deal with it humanely and to uh
and to stop what's happening the
president of mexico
disagrees this is happening because of
trump he blames
biden expectations were created
that with the government of president
biden there would be a better treatment
of migrants
and this has caused central american
migrants and also from our country
wanting to cross the border thinking
that it is easier to do so the president
doesn't think that's what's happening
it's not like someone sits around
somewhere in
guatemala and says i got a great idea
let's sell everything we have give the
money to a coyote
have them take our kids or us to the
border of america
take us across leave us in the desert we
don't speak the language won't that be
fun at government-run shelters in the
last year 2 900
unaccompanied children have tested
positive for covid including 300 in
custody right now according to axios
and kovid didn't come up today but
bipartisanship
did i also look forward to working with
members of the congress to date
white house outreach to republicans has
been limited when was the last time you
had a conversation with president biden
even on the phone i don't believe i've
spoken with him since he was sworn in
and now the pressure is on the vice
president i said when we uh became a
team and got elected that
the vice president is going to be the
last person in the room
she didn't realize that means she gets
every assignment
they met privately about immigration for
more than an hour before the president
moved on to an event about
equal pay for women with the u.s soccer
star megan repino
on this the eve of his first solo press
conference as president a few minutes
ago somebody shouted out to him
how are you getting ready for the press
conference and he said
what press conference brett do you have
a good question
ready i have a binder full of questions
it's been a while wonderful yeah so
you'll you'll alternate
depending on what happens well let's see
if we get called on
and then uh we we will see where the
where the moment takes us
okay peter thank you we trust in you
thank you
to